okay for those who are joining a
livestream this is a meeting about a
collection of different features in both
language which have been tagged as
experimental and which we are trying to
polish and move towards being non
experimental so let's start off with
initialization related functions look
very promising in terms of our desire to
D experimental eyes them Roman I think
these are your functions yes I mean last
meeting we decided that all the
persistence functions should remain
experimental so the initialization
builds on top of persistence so I think
we how much usage of these things got so
far well persistence has has got some
usage in terms of using it for caching
for some of our features like we saw
subjects initialization so I mean for me
if I say what is initialized the compass
values yes I mean initialize is more or
less at the moment than in an internal
function that does the initialization of
a certain variable it will become the
entry point into the kernel
initialization in the future so the the
moment the point is you say initial
initial value of some symbol equals
something and then the next time you
start the kernel that symbol will
automatically be set to that value so
initialize is still under development
okay but so how does this relate to what
we're doing with PAC lots and padlet
loading and so on this is related or is
is unrelated
no I mean packet loaded packard is about
loading code and initialization is about
setting symbols at the start of a
session
mm-hmm all right so what's our plan for
getting us out of experimental okay once
we consider the persistence to be stable
enough and the initialized without any
arguments we'll work to duplicate the
kernel initialization then one more
thing that is needed is the
initialization browser because as soon
as we have yes support persistent values
then we need some easy ways of for users
to browse these values do we have a
modified initialization browser I'm
working on it and within the next few
weeks I should be able to present it
then we see I mean this the design is
not difficult but it requires some
thought about the UX for example do we
want to put it into the positions into
the system preferences or do we want it
to keep separate or things like that I
suspect it should be in preferences but
but the way that preferences works has
not been uniform eyes between the cloud
and the desktop well act I've never try
to use
preferences in the cloud but I mean but
they don't work the same way I mean the
curl preferences in the cloud are much
more modern in some ways but they're not
as as large and complete as the ones in
the desktop no I think we need the
persistence the initialization browsers
for both environments and that's the
same way I mean right now the
preferences here are mostly contained
here under this right these are
preferences here and there's a bunch of
preferences but this is nice and modern
but it's definitely a pale shadow of the
Preferences but to our settable here all
right this is a big preferences system
yes I mean are there any attempts to to
unify the tool there haven't been but
there probably should be and that
probably should be part of the I mean
probably should have a custom meeting
specifically about this I mean I you
know I don't even know you know some of
this stuff like maximum output size
before truncation I mean that's
something that probably could be
settable in the in the cloud although
it's the parameters are just completely
different because it has to do with you
know browser performance and networks
and things like this yes certainly
parallel would I mean it's the first
time I think about it but certainly this
panel would want its equivalent for the
clouds parallelism before the private
cloud fine
well I mean I think fundamentally what
we want to do I mean like like this is
completely different story right I mean
that's a completely different story for
the for the cloud mm-hmm so I think what
we need to do and ROG if you're covering
this then you know we'll need a meeting
with the pilot yeah you did actually
request this last time so I do I'm good
I'm so deterministic in the same input
I'll come out right so yes we will have
a meeting to discuss how to sync
preferences between cloud and okay but
okay fine but sync as in the design and
so on right correct correct
okay are you high yeah right so that's
it is not it for initialization we're
not the experimental izing at this time
yeah
I agree for it because persistence isn't
okay alright so let's see we do we have
constant in here who's representing but
no so who is representing this section
uh I don't know I pulled why's it here I
don't know why here
okay I'm skip over as I was try to find
him he's a way to gain distance isn't he
I have no idea but who is supposed to be
representing this section constant it is
and he hasn't joined yet so can you
switched it and he's not here so but
okay look this stuff needs to be needs
to be D experimental eyes but it needs
to be checked and there's a bunch of
people who are involved in these things
for example
what an earth is this who's writing this
here
what what are you talking about that was
cause he doesn't know what he's talking
about
who is Constantine's manager I would
think that would be Tom Tom okay well
you guys could need to get your act
together on this and let's have a
meeting about it but I think we need to
do experimental eyes all these things I
can't see any reason they should stay
experimental okay okay let's move to a
totally different topic which can evolve
a different set of people here um I
assume we have Jonathan and Hosea here
yep hi okay so the folks who were
involved in the initialization scheduled
tasks of except there was nobody
involved with scheduled tasks so the
person not involved with scheduled tasks
and can drop but Roman if you you don't
need to stick around I think to this
okay goodbye good night thank you see
you bye okay find it crazy no proof yes
so our recommendation is that this
should still be experimental because
it's a very recent function and it's
changing so what what aspect of it is
changing yes so first it's being used
now by the future synthetic proof
geometry group so they will be using it
and then we have what aspect of it well
the idea of proof object so they want to
return their results also as proof
objects huh
and then Jonathan can explain better we
are now adding counter examples because
what Meister can also produce contract
samples no that's nice
it's very cool yes so how is that going
to be a return I mean is that really the
same function finding I mean find
equational proof it's like oops there
isn't a proof but here's a counter
example right that's kind of the idea
yeah they will either either return of
proof object or account for example
object whichever it can find first Oh
interesting
and so I can if you want I can show you
the kind of prototype yes okay let's see
I have no idea this was coming
this is cool okay yeah I haven't worked
on this for about a month or so but yeah
so if we have yeah so if you at the
moment if you have a theorem and it's or
you have a statement and it's just
obviously false it will return a failure
object mm-hmm
but if it's if it's something that is
false but it can't be
easily reduce the false it will just
hang so here I'm trying to prove that X
times the identity is the identity
within the axioms of group theory which
is obviously wrong but I've added this
thing called final equation of counter
example which if you now run on that
will return this thing which encodes the
counter example like this and so what
it's doing is it's assigning values to
the operate so here we have just a
multiplication operator and it's give
it's assigning values to this
multiplication table like a matrix
that's like a like a multiplication
table for that object precisely and
everybody what it's doing internally is
is just enumerate a possible
multiplication tables until it finds the
counter example it's actually it's not
doing anything very sophisticated and so
yes so it's encoded like that and then
as I've sort of parallel to the proof
function that's that's in the time limit
so that functionality about you know
essentially enumerated models yep it's
an alternative to the whole you know you
know you could find a proof by enumerate
all possible models and showing that
they will work right except that in this
instance you this is not a finite that
there is no finite set of models that
you could just enumerate I see but in
your counter example finder is there
some way of eventually enumerate in in
principle after an infinite time sort of
spiraling out is the space of all
possible counter examples until you
eventually find one or what assuming
that the statement is decidable then yes
then you or your procedure can
eventually find successively larger
counter examples yes yeah because they
all that it's doing is certain size and
it's got a certain set of elements
discrete set of elements and it's simply
writing down multiplication tables that
progress with greater size is that yes
so so with this binary operator here you
know it starts with just a trivial model
then a two by two table then a three by
three and so on and in this case it just
found one after a numerating a
two-by-two table because this is quite a
simple counter example and it turns out
that in practical cases at least all the
ones that I tried this is efficient and
a half the planet can for example pretty
much instantly and as I was going to say
that instead of parallel to the proof
function
that comes as part of the proof objects
you can request a falsification function
where it actually assigned it in hard
codes this operator and hard cuz you
know the identity elements and so on so
that if you run it in evaluates to false
funky you know by the way if you want to
find ones that are not so easy to find
if you if you retrace that logic axiom
derivation that thing there were plenty
there where it was non-trivial to find a
counter example though it's there were
there were almost almost fully algebra
axiom systems that missed by a quail our
counter example okay
are those available in in case the as
they should be I mean actually I'm about
to write a blog post about this stuff
which will feature a bunch of stuff
about find equational proof and I you
know even over this coming weekend I
might try to write it if I do that I
will be kind of generating a slightly
cleaner version of those old model
enumeration things okay I think when I
did them to the n KS book 20 years ago
I'm pretty sure I wrote C code to do
that stuff like that I'm pretty sure
that was all a bunch of highly optimized
bit twiddling code because it was in
fact fairly you know you had to go a
fairly long distance to find counter
examples there now arguably we could
actually use the very same code because
it was doing the very same thing I mean
it was it was just enumerated possible
you know things of a certain sizes and I
and I I just don't know hopefully
without compiler this will be something
that we pretty efficient to do would it
be sufficiently general that it could
they could work with any equational
system or is it I think it was I mean I
I think it was just I I don't really
know what it I own oh wait a minute it's
coming back to me now
it's going back to me what I actually
did was I actually machine generated C
source code compiled it and ran it so in
other words given the which is what we
could now do with the compiler basically
except going to LLVM rather than C so in
fact this would be an interesting
exercise um
the compiler I would think quite an
interesting exercise and comparatively
easy actually now in terms of design I
am not at all convinced that find
equational proof should actually return
counter example objects I I think it is
I mean I think it would be better to
just say you know failure there isn't
the proof and then separately to have
something which is more of a you know
some kind of model exploring function
that would be more in the nature of you
know with the counter example why does
it need so it has the G and the end I
mean I would have thought that what it
should do I see those are multiplication
tables in the same sense that boolean
table is a multiplication table derived
from boolean function yes and what is
our way of representing how do we go
from a multiplication table so we don't
have a good way I see in a sense your
your way of doing it is if the elements
are labeled by successive integers then
it is simply part extraction to you know
index n to the multiplication table yeah
exactly so it's just a pure function it
was representing the operator is a pure
function that's based on the part
extraction and yeah the fact that
they're integers just makes it
convenient that you know these are just
arbitrary objects right well the more
general case would be a nested
Association that you could use to have
well then you could have arbitrary
objects indexing into it for the
multiplication table okay right because
because all you do is instead of I mean
I'm not sure that's desirable or not but
but um
okay well it's very interesting I'm fine
well I'm convinced that we should leave
it as experimental for now although I
feel like boy I think this needs a
different function I think this model
exploration thing is a different
function and I don't know exactly I mean
right now it is that yeah for the moment
that was just a convenience right but I
feel like what it should return here is
something less I mean since it is
returning finite models you know
basically people are gonna want to get
the models out and visualize the models
and things like this and what you're
giving people here and for example what
they might want to do is this might be a
thing that searches for models and
people might want to just visualize and
they might want to say give me a bucket
of 50 models that satisfy this set of
axioms right but I think we could
potentially follow the the sort of proof
object structure in doing that that you
know we have this underlying Association
but just as we can visualize the proof
networks there might be some nice where
you could just you know call into the
counter example object and say visualize
this as a multiplication table or
something no fair enough but that's
that's with respect to counter examples
what I'm saying is the positive case
namely given this axiom system just get
me a bucket of 50 examples not counter
examples 50 possible models for that
axiom system right there may be a
connection with find instance here
exactly there might be but the the the
reason I'm concerned about that is that
if you're finding models that if you're
trying to do a satisfiability problem
the fact that we've got universal
quantifiers might be a an issue because
what does it even mean to say that if
you're quantifying over all X and you
know X isn't even in a set here this is
just any object X what does it mean to
say that a particular model satisfies
this axiom system well it doesn't the
model come equipped with a with an
alphabet yes okay so in which case we
yeah
we'd have to to find out model so just
like you give I mean what what would
happen is in your setup there you'd be
giving the alphabet as well as the
multiplication tables right yeah so it
would have a domain of discourse right
which it needs to do because it's a
finite model and those multiplication
tables are finite multiplication tables
mm-hmm so I think it needs that and you
know what I would suggest is some kind
of instance finding thing that way you
can either give it the size of the model
or in fact give it the elements that you
want to use in the model unless we just
decide they're always you know
successive integers which we might you
give it the size of the model and it
tells you what some examples or well
right there are two things you might
want if if now you might either want
examples or counter examples and you
might not know whether they're the
things would be yeah right so it either
either is the case that there are
certain multiplication tables which are
examples or there are ones which are
counter examples in the sense that the
the axioms is simply not I mean the
relations are simply not true but I'm
little confused by something wait a
minute
what is the deal so a counter example
means that in the counter example week
that I suppose them primary differences
we have to specify you know what the
what the what the quantified variables
actually are whereas if you're just
giving a model that satisfies the the
axioms you don't because on because by
definition has to satisfy for all yes so
they didn't sleep yeah the structure
would have to be slightly different I
think between the counter example and
the satisfier satisfaction example
yes but both are of interest all right
this this will take another separate
design meeting yeah did you fix the
examples for find equational proof to
structure them better
not yet but Jose and I were talking
about it in our last meeting okay
comment I wanted to make here is that
the thing we have seen users complaining
about is that they expected the function
to understand directly things like x + +
right capital x capital r + so so the
function to know automatically all the
properties of these functions and i I
think that the conclusion that we came
to was that the best thing to do would
be you know if if the user or if someone
puts in a statement involving say the +
operator but doesn't give axioms which
define it then find equational proof
should bring in some sensible yeah
beyond arithmetic or something well
because effectively it's already doing
that for the and operation here yes okay
there is a subtlety that but yes
essentially yeah yeah there is a
subtlety now they think about it because
like if those were axioms of boolean
algebra it wouldn't have an and and it
already I mean that's some yeah that's a
level thing the this this and is being
converted into it is making this a list
of axioms internally right even though
it purports to be a logic operator there
yes I mean in the in the documentation
we explain of those two things are
treated as equivalent ok ok I understand
so yeah I agree with you that is if
you're using built-in system things like
x + + that we should pull an axiom
systems for those yeah and i wonder what
other i mean ultimately then so the
family of that stuff becomes ultimately
we could imagine a thing called group
multiply or group x or some such other
thing which would have the axioms of
group theory built
right yeah that's probably the right way
to do it and many of those things would
not have a um I mean I don't know in our
group Theory subsystem Jose do we have
something which is a group x effectively
we're a group theoretical functionality
is funny dedicated to permutations and
we have a permutation product and we
have also a group multiplication table
and things of that but it's all oriented
toward permutations mm-hmm
it can handle say permit permutation
product of G and H things in that and
then okay so that's another example
where let's see it that's another
example where we could have built in you
know for the permutation product then we
could have built in axiom system right -
correct
well so what's the right but so I mean
are we gonna use P on our arithmetic or
something for the built in axiom system
for x and plus some of that stuff is not
purely equation alright it's axiom
schemas and things
right yeah that would require some work
there is a there is I mean certainly you
can use things like presberg arithmetic
there are equation or forms of that
about it's not strong enough no no an
interesting question is should we have
an ability for find equation or proof to
call on our much more sophisticated
they're improving capabilities that make
use of all of the fancy you know
algebraic structure of things in the
case of plus and times even though then
some steps in the equation of proof
might be kind of Oracle like steps so we
have steps in the proof that would you
know call out serve full simplify oh
yeah for example tell you we're going to
be able to do because because we're not
going to be able to represent well this
this is something that dovetails with
the whole lean Michael correct project
so that would be a great thing to I'd
love to know actually um actually I'd
love to know sooner rather than
later because it relates to a bunch of
things that I'm thinking about what we
might be able to do with that if you're
able to find out from Michael that will
be great I need I don't think we should
take the time right now to do this um
now unless somebody can find Michael
maybe they can find Michael we could we
could try asking the question at least
um Erik you able to do that well yeah I
we keep having meetings with lean
developers and they have been working on
a bi-directional connection now so we
had before connections or lean calling
ever from language now we have also the
beginning of of the opposite direction
okay is there some report about that I
really like to see it because I'm
thinking of writing this blog post about
the logic stuff and I would like to see
that in connection with that James may
be able to show something yes if
somebody could ask him to send that
preferably by the end of the day that
would be great
okay okay okay yep all right I think
this is probably everything for this and
we'll have to leave this experimental
but um okay okay and Jonathan you're
coming to the summer school is that true
yes good good okay
I'll see you there all right nothing
else for this some for the theorem
proving stuff okay let's move on
so Jonathan I was there I think your
part is done here okay okay we have
Sebastian for [ __ ] link yes yes okay
what's the deal here context and I'm not
quite sure what the go ahead gonna say
yes basically only been there since 11.3
and so I base
he said that nothing should be the
experimentalist and there's some things
already we've realized we had the wrong
design why is them no why is this not
showing up but wise [ __ ] not show up as
a as a.m. why is that by the way you
have a bunch of background noise
Sebastian
you
I don't know why this says [ __ ] link
operations wasn't this is [ __ ] link and
why doesn't this get tagged as as
parental on this page
obviously tagged as experimental all
right this this is not ready for
primetime
I mean this is how but but Sebastian
tell me about how it's being used so far
by excuse for internal users anything
anything what's the experience with it
so far so far the main issue that we've
had is is exposing so it's nothing with
having connections to other kinds of
systems where they have vast numbers of
options and sometimes you really want
those options but it's quite annoying to
have to make them into mathematic
options and also there's often new
options that come out and then you don't
know which ones you're not supporting
okay what we've been using this for a
bunch of machine learning data storage
yes exactly yes and and what's using it
for training so you have the [ __ ]
server on your local machine and you can
basically random sample from a massive
data sense it's out of core ok
that's committed in your networks ok but
but I mean so are we trying to make this
be a more consumer eyes thing for our
users as a giant key value store and so
on so basically this interface is
probably going to stay in a very similar
form to what other interfaces to [ __ ]
look like yeah I'm asking the question
are we intending to build a higher level
thing and if so what is that higher
level thing I would assume it's
essentially a key value store is that
exactly it's just a key value song
precisely okay but a key value store
that has yeah but can potentially have a
petabyte of data in it or something yes
it has efficient aggregation pipelines
whatnot
so can do things like random sampling it
can do all sorts of transformations of
the data before it comes back to your
machine what kind of transformations
okay so this transformation would be to
the same drop so it's basically yeah
jettisons like a mathematical innocence
so it's a list of associations what good
and one later element or the whole thing
so yeah the abstraction is that you have
a collection which is just basically a
list of associations and it becomes a
key value store because the Association
has to have a unique key the idol ID
yeah
but otherwise it's basically data
science okay but it's a simplified data
set which happens to be a list of an
association exactly right
so is it the case that we could imagine
having that be a backing for an out of
court data set of that structure
precisely
yes so it does come with limitations so
things like every Association can only
be 16 megabytes for example so this is
there certain annoying things like this
I thought the thing could deal with
giant I mean so those associations are
essentially the metadata of some giant
thing is that right the Association so
no matter byte of data its board as
linked from that Association right well
no it's nice so when one way of storing
a pinta bited data is that each
association is say 10 megabytes and it's
got lots of them I thought they were on
a list they not they don't have keys so
they have a they have a unique vehicle
ID integer or is that something
different
it's manatee generators you can you can
give it a sequential keys if you want
but yeah if it's automatically
generators it's like a timestamp back to
the millisecond or something when it was
created
okay so again what's the so you're
saying this outside list can be of any
length is that correct that's great
okay but each individual Association is
only 16 megabytes Chris okay so this is
one there is a mechanism for
representing files so if you have this a
like video so this is a common
application of the sort of database is
that it's one of the things that it does
very well is that if it can distribute
itself across multiple machines in
different geographical locations yeah
and you can use it as a as a as a
content delivery mechanism and the way
that works then is that you split the
file into multiple associations and then
yeah there's an API for putting it back
together again
okay what is the top level it's so
frustrating to have this background
noise and talking to you that I'm sorry
I said oh what's this very quiet and be
electronic noise of some kind it's like
we're hearing another conversation oh I
see seconds I can give her that
you
you
okay saying that that is better
okay so again but but okay now we're
hearing but okay
never mind that they I'm trying to
understand the top level thing here what
would it look like what is the thing
that we can provide to users based on
data set out of coyly data set anything
else that would make use of this
functionality sure so one of the things
will be dead drop that's a very natural
fit for this data drop is based on its
back but files yeah it's back by five
exactly and that has all kinds of okay
so how would you use this for data drive
you just use that big long to the
millisecond time stamped list as the
successive elements in the data drop is
that correct sure exactly and then it's
a time ordered sequence which is what
you want has anybody ever talked to
anybody about this first I heard about
this being used for data drop so I've
had conversations with the data drop
people and basically they just don't
have time at the moment to react X the
system but they definitely want to if it
is time for it they want to react
attentive using database no no I've
heard that's a silly story before the
the the the arguments for that were
extremely unconvincing maybe they're
more convincing here but it is the
ultimate data stored inside [ __ ] not in
a sixteen megabytes association it isn't
it's got to be stored in a file
ultimately as well if it's a big thing
No so can it can live perfectly well in
in [ __ ] so there's a this is
abstraction called grid of s grid file
system so effectively it does split
things up in the backend into sixteen
megabytes chunks but there's an
interface that I haven't exposed yet in
mongrel Inc that basically makes it look
like it's just a normal file and it
looks perfectly well in the database
okay well this is this
be really worth well to have a
conversation about their to drop in this
but it's not for this meeting and that
should be deliberately scheduled but I
think for what we're doing here basic
bottom line is great stays it's parental
continues to gradually progress we
putting I mean that the whole Munger
link codebase is that something that
we've like put out in you know github or
something or is that there's a process
to Migrator to github it's not on beside
yet but it will be there quite soon okay
by the way one thing we should be aware
of and this is for Roger I guess when we
have done these things of putting some
of the code bases on you know out in
open repositories like github or an open
repository we should indicate that
somehow on the documentation pages also
or something like that okay I can you
get that to Brandon belieu right that
I'll make sure it's in the next doc
design meeting sounds good alright I
think that's it then anything else nope
okay great tell people on this live
stream we haven't had a lot of activity
that I've seen here but will actually be
coming back in about 15 minutes for
another episode in machine learning um
so until then see you later
see you later ROG Sebastian etc yep bye
bye